[Música]
cientos de libaneses han regresado hoy a
la plaza de los mártires para recordar
que las protestas masivas que empezaron
tal día como hoy hace tres años en todo
el país para exigir el fin de la clase
política y de la corrupción siguen a un
vivas tres años después el país se
enfrenta a una de las mayores
crisis financieras de su historia
después de dos años de la explosión de
beirut todavía no se han tomado medidas
legales y después de seis meses de las
elecciones parlamentarias las primeras
elecciones después de nueve años Todavía
no se ha elegido gobierno son muchos los
motivos por los que los libanneses han
salido hoy a manifestarse Y es que la
situación es realmente desesperante ya
que hay cientos de miles de familias que
están ganando menos de 100 veces al día
y la gente vive con dos horas de
Electricidad al día
cientos de miles de millones siguen
todavía congelados en el fondo monetario
internacional a la espera de que el
Líbano puedan aprender nuevas reformas
económicas y también para que se forme
un nuevo gobierno mientras la
desesperación ha llevado a muchos a que
tengan que tomar su propio dinero de sus
propios bancos atracando la sucursales
bancarias o que cientos de libaneses y
refugiados tengan que jugarse la vida en
la mar buscando un futuro mejor en
Europa ya que aquí no tienen futuro